[Music]
I'm in the 2014 e3 downtown Los Angeles
this is the gaming and tech conference
they're gonna give you all kinds of
games that I've been anticipating games
like I said overthrown
sunset overdrive that's a game I can't
wait to play they've also been a project
more project Morpheus is one of my
favorites can't wait to get my hands on
that I rule warriors a road warrior just
a game I really want to
Hyrule warriors very excited to be here
[Music]
two souls who are in love but they can't
be together and one soul is represented
by a fish another one is represented by
a poet that is such a sweet spiritual
game yeah there's no murder there's no
killing there's no blood oh my it's very
light it's romantic it's nice what I
think it's very meditative - no one's
going to buy this okay I'm checking out
a new Xbox one game sunset overdrive and
you're the mastermind behind this game
I'm the game director you are Amish no
the only Amish game director Yeah right
the game is made of wood and homemade
butter whole world is interactive so you
can be jumping around bouncing around
doing all kinds of cool cool movement to
this playground of a city okay you
shouldn't really skate along power lines
I've tried it no I'm impotent now
one-handed dragon here okay set him on
fire
yeah tell you about the one-handed
dragon
got me feelin motion high school scab
King is coming out there he is and he's
unhappy you're trying to get that crown
back that he's wearing why do you need
that crown of one of the friendly groups
that you're allied with they survived
because they were their LARPers
live-action role-playing people you know
the people like Dungeons & Dragons
playing it like it'll park real life
yeah and so I haven't understood a word
that you've said sometimes this is a new
game called Kevin Spacey in your face he
yells at you for 24 hours a day seven
days a week
hey I'm here with Dan and he's gonna
show me how to play for two is it
Fortson it's worth it alright so while
we're loading a little bit about this
track it is 16 miles you're okay
Nurburgring it's in Germany
[Applause]
[Music]
fine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I am now going to play project Morpheus
on PlayStation 4 this is Anton you're
gonna be going down a street on a luge
and so to get you the best kind of
immersion feeling we're actually gonna
lie you down this beanbag so you guys
fought that's sitting up on a couch or a
chair in videogames was asking too much
the player you want them collapsed in a
sack the party's Markus is the virtual
reality headset it works for PlayStation
4 and the game we're showing today is
the luge does this mean no control arm
no control yes controllers well you're
gonna be steering with your head can I
say lying on this bag is fantastic I'm
getting excellent lower back support so
very high quality bag yeah now am I
allowed to urinate into this there's a
rumor that you can urinate and defecate
into these and it will remove the waste
is that true for you Conan anything all
right I'll go for it all right so I'm
gonna put this gun in your head okay do
you see a virtual image yes I say
virtual image oh my god
it's incredible I finally have manly
legs so what you're gonna do is there's
cars coming up and you can go next to
the cars you're gonna come oh yeah why
would cars be on this road
alternative speed boosts there shouldn't
be cards trying to lose that's gonna be
a truck you can go under it you can go
under a truck
[Applause]
right
[Laughter]
I like this world better than the world
I'm in so you said I'm alone in this
room
right there's just you but what about in
the real room no one's seeing this right
now
I mean not really they're all again okay
Anton you have any kind of oil or
liniment
hey I just bumped into this guy Glen
Glen you don't look like anybody else
here you look like you just want a dance
competition what's going on who are you
I'm the electrician here I don't know if
that's a good thing you're gonna
electrical engineer yeah but look at you
you you've got the flipped up collar you
got the bangs you've got the necklace
doesn't say III to me it doesn't say III
at all this says I'm here to sell you
cocaine this is the dream I had every
night
and now it's come true fantastic what's
the game Hey ladies guess what I got to
play legend of zelda what do you think
who wants to play with me
let's all go
what are we going to do alright now
choose your one-handed sword for your
fire on I'm gonna choose the fire ride
[Applause]
I don't know why that's funny
[Music]
[Applause]
when you double high-five someone you
don't grab on to the hand no you did
that look at the tape
last today at e3 if you're interested
I'd love to show you the coolest thing
I've seen here today
do you want to see it
[Music]
just feel just just relax and put your
head back
just it's isn't this I haven't been this
relaxed in so long it's fantastic
he's Glen here I just want you to watch
while I lie there with these two ladies
this watch who's creeped out raise your
hand if you're creeped out raise your
hand if you're freaked out okay why am I
not cleared up Glen why are you why are
you not freaked out watch the road
okay all right now I'm creeped out you
create the saw that way all right well
from ee3 this is Conan O'Brien living
the life peace out Tupac loves to your
mom's I love this chair
[Applause]